so anna here we are we're back this is
i've been
i've been on twitter all morning with
regards to this and people
are like psyched but like fans are hyped
in a way that
it's like a frenzy are you ever used to
that now
no not really uh the more frenzied it
gets the more i kind of like
back away a little bit because it's it's
really intense
and it keeps getting the fandom keeps
growing more people keep buying the
books more people are watching the movie
more people are excited for the second
one
so i think i just kind of like watched
the tornado happen
it feels pretty intense what was the
difference for you second time around
like
being involved in film uh well
creatively i had a lot more power
and a lot more control on the creative
obviously a film is still a
collaboration but
with the first one i was definitely more
like oh yeah anna's here
like nobody really cared what i said and
this time it's like what i said really
mattered and what i brought from what
the fans wanted really did matter and i
was taken
once i proved myself as a creative
producer i was taken a lot more
seriously
um and once i you know was really out
there at 5 00 a.m
and not uh just hanging out and all
these things i got to learn a lot and it
really
was just a great learning experience
professionally even for me
yeah can you talk to us about finding uh
the perfect trevor when you cast dylan
so it was i mean dylan made it really
easy to
find the perfect trevor he we went
through like a couple
different ideas of people before because
the fans had
like ideas of cast that they wanted um
but then the mom at dylan's name came up
jennifer gibgot who's the other creative
producer with me
we were like yep dylan this is it uh
he'll be great he's so funny he's really
great in this film called banana split i
don't know if you've seen it but
he's really great in that um and it
proved that he has range he just brings
this like light
casual but intensity to trevor that
creates a lot of problems for hardin and
tessa but
dylan really is like the perfect balance
between hero
yeah when you see um when you see an
actor portraying your character on
screen does that sort of
change your own dynamic like your own
relationship with that character
so does that open up parts of the
character you didn't think
maybe you had thought of before how does
it change things for you
yeah it does i mean with each character
is a little different i like this
question
by the way that's a good question um it
does with each one
um with hiro with the second movie he
really understood his character a lot
more
so it was nice to watch him really be
able to be hardened like in the first
one
i could tell just being there that he
didn't really
fully understand the character um
because you're only you only know what's
on the page you know
so uh that was really cool to watch him
really embody harden
and then with dylan and trevor he
dylan kind of made trevor his own thing
and it was really cool to watch because
he actually
improved the character i while i was
writing after i really trevor
just got on my nerves and he was really
just like a plot device to
drive the characters crazy and dylan
really brings him to life
and josephine i mean since day one has
always been
just spot on with tessa so with her it
was just watching her evolve with the
character was really cool but
she's always just been like top of her
game tessa
all day every day yeah can you explain
to people watching that they don't know
about the books the effing trevor thing
yes so i when i was writing the books
i hardin kept calling trevor effing
trevor
every time he would say his name and i
didn't really even notice it like i knew
he was doing it but i didn't really
think of it and then the fans in the
comments on wattpad which is a
basically a virtual writing platform uh
started commenting like effing trevor i
think trevor i think trevor and then
they started making their own t-shirts
and all this stuff and i'm like
it became its own tagline even more than
i ever intended it to be
so now it's just literally like effing
trevor is trevor and that's his name
and that's who he is so with people
in uh in lockdown getting to enjoy this
film
couples together maybe watching this
what do you think it's going to do for
them
are they going to be like looking at
their own relationships
maybe blowing them up or are they going
to be all making babies like what's
going on
what do you want uh i think there's
going to be both i think it's gonna be
if you i feel like it could easily be
both
honestly because there's a lot of um
turmoil
and a lot of darkness in the second
movie especially compared to the first
the books are pretty dark like the
content is pretty dark
and the first movie isn't necessarily
representative of that so with this one
i think there's going to be a lot of
people
um reflecting on themselves or the
relationships they're in
but i think there's also going to be a
lot of people that are enjoying the more
intimate sexy scenes
and you know covered babies all over the
place
they're all going to be named acting
travelers right exactly
so after this all this whole thing ends
like are we going to see
book 3 before like are we gonna are we
getting back in um
in filming in filming mode like what's
the deal um i can't really say much yet
but i can say
to stay tuned to what we're up to
because if all goes to plan of course we
would all love to
bring three and four together so we'll
see